2023 was the first year that I have gone
to a fire Festival in quite some time
since before the pandemic and one of
those questions that I had in my mind
was can the fire festivals come back
from the decline that they were on
before the pandemic and based upon what
I saw this year I think the answer is
maybe and I want to get into why that
answer is complicated Drex here from
Drex Factor po sharing with you the love
of Po spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today yes I am
back on my BS with the flow festivals
and before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel Becca beonin thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so one of the
reasons I was excited coming into 2023
is that for the first time since before
the pandemic I was going to go to some
fire festivals I was really curious to
see what had changed what had stayed the
same what did people want from their
events what things were still lacking
where were public tastes at and even
though I only went to two events I do
feel like I got at least a taste of that
and in the
process I got some pieces of feedback
that I really wasn't anticipating right
before one of these events I had a
conversation with a friend that I have
known for quite some time and in it I
wanted to pick his brain I wanted to
hear if he thought that there was a way
for for-profit flow festivals to
actually become sustainable and to
thrive in the future partially I did
this because he is in a region where the
flow events are publicly subsidized and
also too you know he has a background
with some business in it and he's a
smart guy so I was really curious what
he had to say and somewhat to my
surprise his answer was that he thought
it was unlikely and the specific reason
why is something that has stuck with me
now for months and that I kind of want
to put into words as I'm summarizing my
thoughts for this year and starting to
look at next year namely his opinion is
that flow artists bu and large do not
make a lot of money which true but more
specifically that he thought that
efforts to try and extract value from a
community that already has a low amount
of capital in it was pretty much doomed
to run into some big problems and I get
what he's
saying but there was something very
curious to me about the way he was
framing it so that's a pretty specific
turn of phrase what exactly does it mean
well in the business World usually when
they say value extraction what they mean
is that the actual use value of a thing
is significantly less than the pered
perceived value of the thing uh the term
gets thrown around a lot when talking
about the ways that different companies
try and get ever more uh dollars out of
you for essentially the same product for
example uh recently The Beatles released
a new song which really only had two
living Beatles performing on it and uh
was mainly made up of outtakes and demos
that the two non-s surviving Beatles had
contributed to resulting in kind of a
Frankenstein track that you know in the
grand scheme of things you could argue
coasts on the brand name of the Beatles
in order to get people to buy a track
that you know might just be something
that John Lennon never intended to
finish and was just a throwaway that he
had sitting on a tape recorder now I
don't think the person that I was
talking to specifically meant to use
that turn of phrase in that specific way
I think more what he was referring to
was trying not to have artists that
already don't make a a whole lot of
money have to pay even more for access
to a service that you know maybe we can
subsidize it so they don't have to but
the use of that turn of phrase is still
something that I find very interesting
because one of the biggest challenges I
see in the flow Arts Festival world is a
lack of value ad or value creation and
there's a tension between those two
things so do bear in mind that we are
kind of distinguishing here between the
perceived value something and the actual
use value of something so for example if
somebody shows up to a flow festival and
they think that they're going to have an
amazing time and they show up and it's
really clickish they feel really
overwhelmed they don't enjoy being there
and when they get home they kind of feel
like they dropped a couple hundred
dollars to go participate in something
that just made them feel even more alone
in which case the use value of the thing
was not very high if on the other hand
they go to a flow festival and get to
hang out out with all of their friends
have a great time listen to some cool
DJs and spin fire in a way that they
don't normally get to then yeah the use
value is actually quite high and at
least in my perception one of those
things that the flow festivals have
consistently been falling short on in
the past decade is that they don't
really innovate or add new offerings so
to speak for all intents and purposes
it's a party that you go to in tailgate
with your friends for the weekend and
there's nothing wrong with that but at
the same time there's only so much that
repeating that experience is going to
appeal to people and you either have to
innovate and create something that is
going to have even more use value or you
just go with the fact that you're going
to have a high degree of turnover and
you have to put an enormous amount of
effort and resources into bringing new
people through the door so granted this
is just my perspective and it's more
based on Vibes than anything else but
overwhelmingly I get the feeling in the
past decade that that flow festivals
have done neither of these two things
they have tended not to innovate or
create new value and they haven't put a
whole lot of effort into marketing or
Outreach they haven't tried to reach
Beyond people that are already in the
flow Festival ecosystem or the flow
ecosystem in general for that matter and
that does kind of create a problem and
inevitably means that ticket sales go
down as has been the case I have a
slightly different view on these things
cuz in my mind I know tons of flow
artists that will save up all year in
order to get tickets to go to say a
music festival or travel abroad to like
Costa Rica orali or what have you and
going to a flow Festival is just not
that high of priority why because they
believe that they're going to get more
value out of going to Costa Rica or
going to a music festival than they will
a flow Festival that is flow festivals
are putting so little of perceived value
on the table that they wind up pretty
low in the priority list and rather than
trying to find a way to make up that
difference in a lot of respects it kind
of feels like the festivals have just
kind of seated that ground they've just
kind of given up and said yes we will be
second or third or fourth priority and I
think that inevitably means that
attendance is going to continue to
dwindle now it does need to be said at
this point that not all flow festivals
are the same flow Festival
and specifically that there are a whole
host of different formats structures and
you know even offerings at a variety of
different events that cater to different
groups of people I'm kind of talking in
aggregate here rather than trying to
single out any one Festival is doing a
particularly bad job or a particularly
good job I think that just in general
this is a problem in the industry we've
kind of accepted that we're going to
play second fiddle even to people that
we should be appealing to and if that's
the case if we're just going to seed
that ground then I'm sorry to say but I
I think the decline of the flow
festivals is just going to continue so
what's the solution well some festivals
as I mentioned have gotten themselves uh
subsidies so that they don't really need
to be big successes in terms of ticket
sales in order to keep operating that is
one possible solution I'll be at one
that I think is probably not going to
scale too terribly well and may not work
out of certain regions in the country
another option would be that if we see a
lot of festivals failing that might be
an opportunity for other people to come
in with new ideas and new models and see
if those work the ultimate irony in a
lot of cases is that I think that very
explicit in the value proposition for a
lot of flow festivals is that they don't
change they don't innovate they don't do
things significantly different from year
to year that creates something that
people expect and anticipate something
that they kind of ground themselves in
in a lot of respects but the flip side
of that though is that there's only so
many times people want to have the exact
same experience before they start to
grow tired of it and they want some kind
of novelty at a certain point we have to
decide whether it's more important to
continue to sell tickets to a core group
of people that never ever ever get tired
of having the same thing or whether it's
worth it to try and innovate and reach
out and appeal to new groups of people
as well but what do you all think did
you go to a flow Festival this past year
and if so did you have a good time if
you haven't been to a flow Festival
recently why is that and what could the
festivals do to bring you back into the
fold leave me a comment and please let
me
[Music]
know in the meantime this video would
would not be possible were it not for
the awesome folks that support me over
on patreon in particular I would like to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now um if you
like videos like this where I go into
specific topics and talk about the
broader flow culture I'm glad to hear it
the way that you can support these
videos and make sure there's more of
them is to go sign up to support my work
over on patreon at
patreon.com Factor poy I will include a
link to it down in the description
basically other things that I do for
income such as teaching lessons or say
uh teaching my live stream classes
they're awesome but at the same time
they take away time from creating videos
like this so if you'd like to see videos
like this with better production values
and more research behind them free up
the time for me to be able to do so the
more support I get on patreon the more I
can say no to private lessons and spend
more time on things like this so go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to see more of my videos
about the flow festivals and the culture
around them I will include a playlist of
those down in the description as well as
up on screen if you're watching on
YouTube thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow this weekend
yourself and I'll see you with a new
video real soon peace